récord mario rodríguez vuelve a su
trabajo por primera vez después del paso
del huracán aid a su taller de
reparación de automóviles está
totalmente sumergido su historia es la
misma de miles de habitantes en el
estado de nueva york tengo tres niños
una niña y un buen trabajo es todo lo
que quería en la vida era mi sueño y
ahora tengo la impresión de haber
perdido todo
este es catalogado como un evento
meteorológico histórico en la gran
manzana por ejemplo se rompieron los
récords registrados hace sólo unos días
con las fuertes lluvias descargadas por
la tormenta gente dejando un máximo
histórico de 80 milímetros de agua sobre
el central para la nueva gobernadora del
estado de nueva york dijo que cerca de
20 millones de habitantes podrían verse
afectados algunos kilómetros de allí en
el estado nueva jersey la lluvia también
hizo de las suyas según el gobernador 23
personas murieron mayormente por quedar
atrapados en sus vehículos dentro de las
inundaciones
acá pocas casas están a salvo todo debe
reconstruirse
como miembro de esta comunidad puedo
asegurarles que la ampliación de las
donaciones y del apoyo que ha surgido en
el curso de las últimas horas es
simplemente increíble
en esta zona cerca de 1400 hogares
siguen sin electricidad
sus habitantes se organizan para
retornar de nuevo a la cotidianidad
awacs olvidó que todo el mundo busque
noticias sobre sus vecinos y sus
familias y sus amigos para asegurarse
que van bien nosotros seguimos nuestras
encuestas en nuestros controles en la
zona impactada por la tormenta
tim burton al menos seis estados de la
costa fueron tocados por el huracán
desde maryland hasta connecticut el
presidente joe biden viajará a luisiana
recorrer a las comunidades más afectadas
y se reunirá con el gobernador del
estado quien le presentará una larga
lista de necesidades para la
reconstrucción